okay hello everyone again
we are in an intense season of design
reviews around the version 13 release
which is coming up soon
and in our second design
review of the day second of three
we are looking at more about video
so let's see where have we got to so far
we were looking at um
um i think we wanted to revisit the gui
for the in notebook player and we have
the people that you asked for last time
here john foles from the front end
and
i forgot who from ui it was um christina
yeah
okay great thank you
okay all right so now how do i get a
video up to look at
if you want to open up the video ref
page get the kaminanda sample video we
have an example data
why is this spinning like crazy
why was that spinning to open this page
it looks like that data set from
information is being weird
i'm not sure is
yeah
okay so that needs to be locked up
okay here we go oh so it's now default
so it went full screen
is that what one wants
that the video open opens sort of full
width of the notebook
i think the image size heuristics we use
here is the same as image width
it doesn't go beyond the width of the
notebook by the way this is what is the
state before that is some
debug debugging thing that we still need
to figure out there is some weird
behavior of dynamic module and that was
the easiest way to communicate that with
lou
okay so wait a second so let me
understand the size again
okay
why are you picking so this is full
width effectively is that correct yes
but but if i'm understanding correctly
if the movie were
smaller
i mean if if the frame size were smaller
then
you know it could end up being narrower
than the width of the window it's just
that this particular movie happens to be
fairly
is that right
correct
yeah
yeah so that seems reasonable to me
how is the how is the size determined
from the movie properties is it is it
based on points or pixels
pixels points oh yeah sorry never mind
never mind me
what's that
i was asking whether the movie size was
points or pixels well this is cool so
this is now playing so there's something
i can play multiple movies here
so can i be playing multiple ones at the
same time yes yes
in fact this is much like a demo i gave
at the tech conference
um last year um where's the audio coming
from for these
is it superimposed i think it should be
all three of them yep
so again
it should be all three of them
playing at the same time
yes
okay so two comments here
ethan assassin did
you fix the frame rate degradation of a
time problem i.e gets choppier or slower
over long times
that must have been a basic problem
anybody know it might have been a
problem with the previous guide that was
using the kernel to do the coding so
hopefully this will not show that
okay
this is a completely different backhand
for
uh feeding frames to the
notebook this is using uh
library link support in the front end
okay ethan has a
um
uh can
can he take
multiple videos
synchronize
put them in a grid synchronize them and
export the resulting thing
well there is a very nice function that
you can see in the video creation
section that we are proposing
it's called videograde yeah exactly
that's exactly that
okay
wonderful all right okay
all right let's let's finish off on our
ui discussion okay
so
if i take this
oops no resize
no the size is the the lack of resize
depends on the fact that this is using
template box which kind of prevents
using the usual
orange frame with the draggy thingy that
is present in graphics and an image
there might be a way around that but you
will not want to do that
yes it can be done uh
you just have to know how to do it and i
thought
i thought that had been communicated in
a way that you understood but if not i'm
happy to follow up i know how to do it
with pain box but it will not look like
the resizing an image as far as i
understood from what lou said to me
um
[Music]
okay
i just want to confirm what the what the
behavior should be you click here in the
image what's supposed to happen then
you're supposed to get the resize
handles up yes
well so that's a good question i mean
do we
do we want it to
to be treated as a traditional selection
that
might have implications uh for or you
know that might suggest
certain user interface things that maybe
aren't possible
well what what what else would a click
do well so maybe maybe the the selection
that should be showing should be
around for example uh should be around
not the image but the entire player
i don't think so i think this should be
maybe we have other places cases of that
given the image size
the player bar should adapt itself to
the image size
it does now if you make your notebook
narrower
you can see that behavior
nice
okay if i make it wider
it maxes out at the raw pixel size of
the video is that correct correct
but but so for example you know what
happens if you
uh
you know if you click on it with a
selection and you press uh backspace or
delete
uh
do you you know presumably the whole
player object would be deleted not like
what just happened i hit backspace what
happened
help
i think that's selected now
right
okay then it went away
so it took two
clicks to make it go away
right
that that that's uh
that's not uncommon for this type of
construct two two backspaces which which
mean
but but if if you click on it
and the click makes a selection
and then you're expecting backspace to
delete it
i would sort of expect the selection to
encompass everything that's going to be
deleted
which includes
there's another thing in the in the
other interface which doesn't have a
scroll bar
you know kind of we want to use click to
pause and play right
that's what we do now and in fact just
before the meeting carla and i were
discussing whether this appearance as
well should do that it's really
convenient
to be able to click somewhere on the
image to play and pause well and and so
that's another good question is if
clicking is playing and pausing then
then should it be selecting
well i know but
i think people are going to want to
resize this image i think that's going
to be a pretty common thing
should it have a frame around it that
you that you can grab and resize or
possibly
what
what carlo was experimenting with this
morning was a resize area just like we
have
um next to some other things
so when you hover over it that could be
this frame that shows up that you kind
of click on it can resize
nicely on hover you could get a frame
that you can then go and select that
kind of thing yeah
what could be the the whole thing
it could be yeah
yeah
okay
but then
what's the indication when you click
inside where how do i get the other
display type
uh right click on
switch to minimal appearance
those are obviously not the final names
those texts are going to be updated
i think you should call it in-dash
notebook
i mean we do have also other quiz
well i guess maybe we'll have to discuss
this if we drop the ones that look like
this but go through the kernel i guess
they can be dropped why would you want
that
yeah no probably don't
yeah we discussed it carlo internally we
said with some internal flag we can
switch to
to that other backend we had before but
not from the gui okay that's yeah i
forgot about that
okay
so i mean we could just say switch to
minimal appearance switch to
must everything basic and minimum what
what's the non-basic
both of those are going to be in
notebook the other one would be a
thumbnail which we had before
i think we should be able to still
switch back to that as well why not yeah
why not
but both of these basic and minimal are
gonna be in notebook and we discussed an
advanced could have things for
multiple position selection and things
like that so that's still going to be
something for future
okay but then in the video wrapper
there's an appearance option which
allows you which has
these different string names for the
different appearances that correct
correct yes
okay
all right so it's thumbnail
um
well i'm about to find out what minimal
is
there is some weirdness on the sizing of
that button it should not be that tiny
what should we call this one those two
versus
um
player
or minimal
thumbnail player minimal
you're calling this one that we call
basic player
yeah because it has a player in it
it has
a scroll bar i mean you mean um what is
that thing called i thought that was
called a what is that called
it's
it enables
it has a name those things have a name
yeah they do
what is it
i mean i might refer to it as a control
bar
i haven't seen that
some kind of track or something
okay there's also the question being
raised on our live stream
about
being able to embed
the video in the notebook as in embed
the data for the video in the notebook
which it isn't right now right
right yeah
so that's the same thing that we have
with data set and all kinds of other
things
sort of
i think is this is starting to straddle
another issue which is sort of assets
i know but
one of the things
that we know we want to do
right because
you know with data set
but it's a question of do you store the
whole thing in the notebook and you have
an option if it's big whether you want
to do that or not same thing should
happen with video
ah scrubber yes that's what i i've seen
that somebody on livestream k is saying
that that
this thing is a scrubber
why didn't it change wait wait why
didn't it change that little creature is
why isn't it changing oh that is a bug
okay
what do you mean
the quick little creature
in the messages window that is the root
of this bug
changing the appearance messes somehow
okay this is the stage with something i
do not know exactly the details but i
will have to yeah uh
i'm sure that you can fix it for now by
just reevaluating the input okay fine
yep
okay but but
so okay
first point is the graphic appearance of
this seems pretty good to me
what do other people think
is this
standard for audio sorry but
that's the time it is so far and that's
the total time correct
yes
but so if i do audio capture
for example
hello i'm captu whoops hello i'm
capturing
what happened there see that little
circle is broken there come on
see that circle being broken
i do see i hadn't seen it before
okay
all right so that doesn't have
in the audio player now
first of all is that blue the same as
that blue yes
oh i see so there
look what you're doing
um
yeah the reason is that typically we
don't have a whole lot more to show in
the audio
so we wanted that object to be smaller
no i understand that but i'm saying that
you you're putting the
in gray
those times as footnotes basically to
the slider yep
so i'm i'm suggesting maybe they should
be in gray here what do you think oh
just for the color
maybe or the position as well
um
okay christina is commenting maybe
that's the christina who's actually here
who could use audio voice
commenting what about a full screen
option
guys yeah that seems standard okay
um i am not exactly sure how that worked
out
with the notebook but the notebook
becomes full
i think it should be more open in system
player
which in this case didn't work
that's what i would do i wouldn't have
it be the notebook i don't think i am
i'm tending to agree
i'm perfect that was my
thought as well
okay so it's basic why is opening system
players dead right now
the the the main thing is that you want
open and system player you want to of
course you want to
stop the notebook movie from playing and
make sure open system player has all of
the same attributes that you know
position and that sort of thing that the
is currently in uh um uh in the notebook
versus a player
that's interesting i am
i'll have to figure out how to do that
because at the moment i don't think i
have any idea because i assume it is
very
player dependent for example this one
has vlc instead of
whatever the operating system is oh oh
okay i'm okay i didn't sorry i didn't
realize that uh
you were gonna be
using a uh
not our software but potentially
somebody else's software um i don't
think we can yeah
sorry
well so
four on our livestream is saying can you
pop out the video which is essentially
opening system player or is it not is
there a difference between opening our
own popped out player versus opening the
system player oh we do not have our own
popped up player
yeah that's what i didn't understand but
now i do
okay fine so it's just the system player
yeah all right but so
we can still say full screen it will be
full screen in the system player
right
so when you exit the full screen it's
actually pretty good behavior as far as
i'm concerned i mean i hate these things
that leave you in some weird full screen
mode if you exit full screen
then you would get back to a small
system player which you can then you can
then close and then you're back to the
notebook that the thing came from right
yes that seems good but the notebook
wouldn't be updated with anything that
you did in the system player
correct
so if you save it for now yeah yeah okay
i mean one day we might have our own
standalone player but let's not worry
about that yet
um
okay so
okay so this would have a full screen
there would be a full screen button as
well here correct
i think or should there be a pop out
there aren't these incredibly standard
things in player controls both full
screen and pop-up well i mean but the
problem is is that
full screen of course isn't
just full screen it's open in system
player and so do we
do we want to do exactly the standard
thing
i would we could have a little curlicue
on the icon to indicate it's opening in
a different player
i i yeah i think we should do it we
should have something which looks
colorably like the standard icons
okay but have we resolved the question
of what to do
okay if
on hover we bring up the controls
then we cannot also have the controls i
mean it will be super annoying every
time you're going to stop or pause the
movie
that
it also is bringing up all this regalia
around the side
to resize
i mean most people don't have the
possibility of resizing a movie right
that's a
somewhat unique thing to us
i think it's you do get the choice
between a few standard sizes in other
players
why don't we show off the fact that we
have better than that yeah quicktime
which you had as your default player
however does for instance allow for
resizing easily dlc as well yeah
how do they resize they just resize the
window yeah just just correct okay fine
but we we have an outer window
so the whole point is we have a window
and window situation
right so the question is what do you do
to resize the inner window
okay so
i agree with you that any hover showing
all of those control appearances is odd
but maybe again we can just leave with
one
on one of the four corners
no i'll be even more confusing
um
look the point is in notebooks people
are used to the idea
that you click an image to resize it i
mean that's what all of these images do
it's what we've consistently done on all
other images
but
that means that clicking an image is
going to make it is going to give it a
selected appearance as well
that could be considered annoying if all
you were trying to do was pause or
unpause the movie i know that i know
that so that's a bad thing but let me
point out something else here okay so if
i do a manipulate here
okay
i have a resize there
so this is somebody was commenting that
you shouldn't now if i do resize that
and i do oh my gosh i can delete that
really
really
how did that work
what just happened there
they deleted the innards of the
manipulate yeah well i suspect this
because the enders of the manipulate
didn't depend on x
that would be my guess
just confirm that because that's really
weird that i could do that
um
nope
oh my gosh
and then when i click it comes back
yeah
well that that's kind of sorry that's
kind of what i meant
okay
well i see because the other one didn't
the dynamic wasn't triggering yeah
that's very weird
okay but the main point here is this
thing
and and and of course i mean this is the
essential problem right okay so now now
if you wrap deploy around that uh you
won't be able to accidentally delete it
but you also can't resize it
yeah i get it by the way one thing ux
wise that plus sign should probably in
modern times be a dot dot shouldn't it
or maybe not no no no it's a plus
no it's an opener
okay
okay
so for some reason it's slightly offset
but okay so what are we doing here
um
by the way dude is jeremy here
no
no
but we were going to review the graphic
design of this also
i can get them
good i think it's not bad but the
graphic design that's here but okay so
we still haven't resolved this question
about what happens when you click
um
whether in the scrubber view
whether
clicking on the video itself you know
this is my problem for not watching
enough videos on on online
um or at all in fact um
how from how you
familiar is it i mean so if this video
was really going to stop start with a
click obviously the mouse appearance has
to change
yes
i don't think so no no
what do you expect it to do guys because
i don't know what do you expect a
generic video to do if you click it
player pause
player pause yeah
and it's indicated how it's indicated by
by pause button sitting in the middle
after you clicked it right
okay but notice that this
doesn't have a pause button pause thing
in the middle because it has it in the
scrubber
just go to youtube and do it
i'm sorry so just just go to youtube and
and do it and you'll see it kind of like
ghosts in and goes out
or minimal gui is the same as well you
do see a pause button i know i know
wow i hate to even imagine what kind of
ads show up on
what is this you could do it even on the
ad you could just click on the okay
yeah just click on the video
see oh
okay but it's really nice because you
don't have to go and search for this my
new little point in the corner okay
i just i just wonder
what
algorithm causes
sawmill equipment
to be the top ad
maybe it's regional i don't know
what's that
it might be regional
well i guess there are trees around here
um
well like all internet advertising it's
incredibly stupid until suddenly it
turns incredibly scary
right right
okay
okay so
is coming in spacebar also pauses the
video
and presumably we will have that too or
what no we won't have no spacebar does
something else for us no uh yeah because
you can be typing
right
while you're watching the video you
could be typing absolutely
okay so clicking on the video
okay so what you're proposing is that
well maybe it has to have a resize
handle somewhere
and that's the other possibility it's
some kind of little resize handle
comments guys
that's what i've been saying yes um
the point is that because we're
re-sampling these videos and because we
have a different environment than other
people's environments
um
all right well so do we have a design
for a resize handle
i think it's a very standard three
diagonals
at the bottom right
okay fine
yeah
okay we got a whole bunch of comments
and um
somebody's asking how do i put ads in
the video
no
that's not what we're signing up for
the
um
but i i still want to address this
question about
keeping the assets in the notebook
do we have a mechanism to do that
no
okay i think we should
how big are these videos how big is this
coming on this video for example
five meg
how much
five megs i think car though
so that will be easy to keep in the
notebook
so otherwise when somebody sends
somebody a notebook with a video keep in
mind that this was handcrafted for
example data it's really a toy example
people playing with
real videos that they have we're talking
about much larger assets
okay so what do we think in reality
somebody sends somebody a notebook and
it has a video in it where's that video
going to be coming from
is it coming going to be coming from our
cloud where is it going to be coming
from
yeah if you want to share i mean this is
a problem that we haven't addressed
because the problem needs to be bigger
more urgent for because several people
is going to be involved in solving it
it needs to be somewhere where
you can point to it like in the cloud
and it needs to be relinked to where
those assets live
yes but so so now look if i want to
embed a youtube video in here how do i
do it can i do that
no
you cannot do that because you cannot
access it except from youtube because of
licensing
i've i've only seen one software package
which can pull down youtube videos and
they're in a constant race with youtube
basically youtube keeps changing things
and they keep changing to update and
and the whole thing is kind of you know
there's dubious legality around it it
hadn't been found
in a browser you can do that right our
embedded service thing does absolutely
yes yep
so that just has the html player
um pointing to the correct url
so if one day we had a webkit
embedded html inside notebooks that
would be fine
but only for playing not for accessing
the frames is what i'm saying we cannot
download it in any way
yeah i mean which which means all your
computational stuff is out the window
you know now it's just a
dead player
right but it still might be useful to
people
okay question
what
what um
let me see the
so where else i mean is it realistic for
these videos to come from a cloud
or is that a bandwidth problem
i mean because clearly
services like youtube
i um
former student of mine was deeply
involved and i may have even run the
thing that was figuring out
um
all of the
encoding flow rate etc type stuff
um
but that's a complicated thing we're not
going to solve that problem for our
cloud for example
right
can you respond i'm asking how are we
supposed to do this somebody tries to
send a notebook with a video in it how
do where do they put the video so my my
immediate reaction which is a very
clunky thing obviously is either
attaching the same email and give a
relative file path or send a link to a
cloud and a url download of that link
i think that the practical thing
is
no no hold on i think that the yeah
the two scenarios is basically the same
but you kind of need you know if you
send a directory with the notebook and
the video assets
and they re you know they link to them
relatively sending a video by email
it's too big
right
right the the the the scenario
of attaching
the video uh same thing with attaching a
notebook i mean it's it's just you know
a tiny size is fine but anything more
than you know 10 megabytes or on some
platforms even smaller you're going to
run into real problems right but the
question is where do you put that
package of bits exactly it can be a you
know it could be your
um
you know your shared files
we can't stream it from our cloud
we could have people download it from
there but i don't think it's going to
work to stream it from that is it
well
there's various improvements that we
made to streaming without even looking
at the server capacity yeah because
one thing that we do so far with the
thumbnail player or with
the only player we have for videos that
are not local are is the thumbnail
player and we open that video in a
browser now
so we don't even attempt to stream in
notebook
any remote asset
okay but so you're saying
if i have a remote thing and that could
even be a youtube video because it's
just going to a browser right
is that correct
um
no because we cannot do any computation
on it right with yes so the whole idea
of having a video of it
no but i understand it doesn't matter if
somebody just wants a decorative video
it can be coming from youtube or
wherever else if it is going to be open
in a browser that's all just fine
well but then is it a video object
anymore i mean a video object is
computation
well it says i'm sorry i can't do that
but we shouldn't stop people from having
decorative videos just because they're
things we can't do with that but does
that but but is it a video object i
think so yes
it just says it's a video object that
doesn't have access to those things
okay i just want to go through again
okay in terms of storage and
distribution why wouldn't we promote our
cloud
i just won't work it won't work it's a
complicated piece of infrastructure to
stream videos you know so i'm talking
about streaming i'm just talking about
that distributing distributing the the
download the import case
why not
well that's fine but okay
streaming is not fine so possibly a
third option i don't know how
interesting this is but a third option
might be
to support uh playing a file that's uh
only been partially downloaded while
it's still downloading
we are
definitely working on that there is
actually
hopefully for 13
part of this will be in
but you know downloading a 30 gigabyte
file
without streaming from the cloud
is complicated i mean it's
it's going to take a while and it's not
clear what the use case is for that
and the question is should that happen
in the background when you open the
notebook
or should you be explicitly downloading
that asset and then having the notebook
point to that asset
you see what i'm saying
in more cases that's that's also not
permissible unless it's on our servers
it is but in for general urls
downloading a lot of times is not
available while streaming isn't
available
yeah but
not streaming into our player only
streaming to a browser yeah
right but but but i'm saying
even if somebody even if it's on our
cloud somebody's got a one gigabyte
video
they want to send somebody the notebook
and they want to trail along with the
notebook the video and the video is in
our cloud
so it's fully downloadable or it's in
some other place you know where it's
fully downloadable you get what i'm
saying
just a blob of bits downloadable from
the web the question is do we want that
to happen so somebody opens the notebook
it's just like you know john is obsessed
with the dynamic content
stuff and putting up warnings for that
do you put a warning when it says this
opening this notebook is going to cause
a 10 gigabyte file to be downloaded to
your computer
do you understand the scenario
so that is something that i do think
that we should develop
no i i want to just understand john and
other people
explain that scenario does that scenario
make sense you open a notebook and then
in the background some file referenced
by that notebook is downloaded does that
make sense
i think that if we're downloading
something big
uh there is some sense to telegraphing
that uh
i mean you know we live
we're back in a day and age where
connections might be metered again
uh
you know sometimes i'm you know my
internet connection is through my cell
phone and
uh you know and and there are multiple
reasons why i might be concerned about
that one is okay fine you might be
consuming i want to know what is the
data limit the other is it might run the
battery out on my cell phone
yeah i get it but i mean so the question
is but is that a basic workflow that we
think we want to support
do you understand what i'm saying i
think so and i think that's more than
one reason for that i think audio video
represents videos it will be done for
data and iconized things and so on yes
exactly okay fine okay we had that
discussion you know while you know
during audio and it had been discussed
prior to that i want to i want to come
back to
the different kinds of videos you know
one thing is the grand feature film okay
a big multi 10 gigabyte object sure okay
another is the scientific video that is
you know the the the splash that's
happening in in um you know it's a few
second video
and it's you know it's scientific it's
small it's 20 megabytes
whatever
right and we're going to be able to take
it apart frame by frame do whatever you
want to it
etc
i would think that these for these
scientific videos being able to store it
in the notebook is really worthwhile
for the feature films it's stupid and
irrelevant
remember making sense
but then what happens if you have
like lots of them in a notebook even if
you're out of luck then it's too
big so i i agree that in principle it
makes sense to embed things in a
notebook but it's you know it's sort of
the
uh
you know if you push it too hard things
are going to start toppling over i
understand that and everybody knows that
because at the file size you know nobody
is expecting that a notebook a 10
gigabyte notebook makes a lot of sense
well there are two issues here one one
is
is that the notebook is going to balloon
a bit faster than the actual file size
it's you know probably something it's
going to be about maybe 15 or 20 larger
by encoding it directly in the notebook
the other is that we have a very
unfortunate two gigabyte limit on
uh notebook file sizes right now it's uh
things are going to start to fix that no
i don't know why you think we fixed it
we have done we haven't done any work on
it all um because we went to 64 bit yeah
i thought we'd gone to 64-bit ui stuff
uh yeah the problem is that uh
uh
the
uh
uh
the problem is that the functions that
we use for accessing files
uh
uh you know are using 32-bit values
um
these are the you know standard c
library uh
you know type things they're using
32-bit values and
and it's a significant uh
significant effort to rewrite these
things i don't think it's the i don't
think that's the most critical thing
right now
i think the multi-gigabyte notebook is a
is a thing for the future
well okay so do we need something that's
that's kind of like a notebook
well
yes yes exactly and and and something
which definitely is on my roadmap so
first of all as
you know as roger says the notion of of
assets and and formalizing these things
uh
uh
and second of all
the notion of a compound notebook file
so you know combine those two things now
you can have a uh you know a compound
notebook file which includes its own
assets
i think that that would be if we
streamline the workflows around that it
will be
quite useful
for the only video i mean for the whole
post oh yes absolutely
totally agreed
okay let's let's review again this is
the stuff okay so now also we've got a
whole bunch of comments on our
livestream so video is an example of big
data
yeah all right okay fine i'm i'm
so i'm sort of retracting the importance
of this store and notebook although i
think it is desirable
but we understand how we would do it
right we understand and and and by the
way we could solve the asset and
compound notebook problem without even
fixing the two gigabyte problem because
you know the notebooks in a cup you know
you know the the archive could be bigger
than two gigabytes yeah i understand i
got it yeah
then
okay so i'm i'm simply asking the the
store and notebook ui
right do we understand what that would
look like
all right so we've agreed that two
additional buttons here which are the
pop out and full screen
right
well
one difference from the other story
notebook uis
is that this one would have to have a
progress bar
because even under the most efficient of
circumstances the the process of
grabbing the data to store it could be
could be time consuming
conditions look like hold on what do the
error conditions look like when the file
is not found
it will just show the thumbnail gui
uh okay i don't think that's how it
looks i think you need some kind of
browser to go find the file or something
some easy way to get to that
did you understand what i'm saying to
reattach to a different file
yes potentially i mean what's going to
happen all the time is somebody's going
to send me this notebook
i'm not going to have the backing video
then i'm going to have to go
somehow you know i say oh please send me
the video oh i'm going to put it here or
oh you can
go to this dropbox link or whatever else
see what i'm saying yeah i i'm guessing
though that will mostly happen in the
input cell rather than modifying the gui
what do you mean by the inputs yeah the
more practical thing would be to change
the path in the input cell rather than
re-linking the output cell
i should say
you mean here
yes
how would that happen i mean what's
going to happen is this is going to be
an error
yeah once you use what does that error
say if i put in there okay if i say
something like if i just say this
okay no this is not the case you
explained we have a video gui
but then when somebody send it to you
the asset is missing so you would see a
thumbnail like what you see on the right
notebook
with the player instead of that play
there is x on it
okay look look guys look we've already
had this mistake right in manipulate for
example
right when manipulate doesn't have save
definitions to true
and you send a manipulate what does it
look like
john
yep sorry i uh
wandered out of headset range what was
the question
what does a manipulate look like when
you reopen a notebook without save
definitions to true and the manipulate
data isn't there
uh
it's going to look exactly like you
evaluated it if it emits messages then
it's you're it's going to pink box
okay but so the case here is in the
notebook there was the frame of video
player but the video behind it wasn't
found what should it do
do you understand my question yeah i
understand the question um okay so let's
have an answer and the answer is not
it's going to look like this
right
this is a great big video player
and presumably you want a great big
video player with some kind of x saying
you can't find the video
is that right
carlo can you speak to that please i
mean i i i don't think the small player
with the big x is inappropriate
so this big player
is suddenly going to turn into a small
player with an x correct correct
my main point is that if you want to fix
things and if you want to do anything by
the things you fix you will have to fix
that input cell and keep in mind
go ahead keep in mind we don't even know
how big the player is supposed to be
if we don't have the asset exactly
all right okay but it's but it's a
different
it's a different display type right you
can't do that you can't change the
display type
no you can't do that because you're
changing that state you've got to have
some
video not found default state for all
the player types
do you see what i'm saying
yep
but also i could i could do
that video that generated coming under
there let's say that i you know i
deleted
the input that could still play right
yes
but then i send it to you and let's say
it was a local file on my system and you
don't have it
then there is no input
yeah right which is a good reason to
have the possibility of having a browser
to go refine the file there
you see what i'm saying rather than a
kernel reevaluation
yeah but even if you redo the thing uh
and when you click in your file browser
and now the gui suddenly works
then just the gui works not all of the
code that lies in the definition of
doesn't matter doesn't matter
i think you guys are not understanding
the points people are not going to just
use this to make to do scientific
analysis of videos
people are going to use this to just put
videos as decoration yes
i see it
we have had that with images right a lot
of times images are a part of a
slideshow or as you said a decoration
but a lot of the times it's the actual
data that needs to be processed yeah
well both things happen yeah but but so
don't just assume that the only videos
of interest are ones which have which
but i don't even understand i don't even
understand that i mean i could take that
video once i've reconnected the video
right i could take it and use it as
input somewhere yeah that is correct
right so so clearly what we have to do
is
if the video is not found there needs to
be a default appearance for this that
makes it clear the video is not found
together with a search for a new video
you see what i'm saying
connect to the resource
rather
well no i mean it's just a browser if
all we can deal with is local videos
right
if all we can deal with at the stage of
the video player is things in a local
file then all you should have is a
browser thing for going to your local
file system
right
yeah we call it a file browser for
anything that file completes
that's fine but then that's what that's
something like yes
carlo does that make sense to you
yep
okay
all right any okay i'm just gonna go
over some of these other comments but
does anybody else have any other comment
before we go on here
nope
okay okay
why doesn't the video why don't the
video controls look like other
attached cell ribbons
asks ethan
okay so
other attached cell ribbons are
selection based
you select it it's there you remove the
selection it's gone
okay
so
yeah in in this case i think you know
you know depending on your player type
you probably or you might very well run
around permanently okay so did did
jeremy join us here
no he did not we we have made attempts
and we texted him and so okay so look
you know guys this is just not adequate
look at this thing see that arrow there
see that it's a different shape than
that arrow there come on we had we have
it on our plan to
make audio and video players more
similar just that we didn't have any
time to spend on this release
i mean this is look this stupid speaker
is a different shape than this one
you've got to fix stuff like that
i i don't disagree at all but touching
wheeze then require testing whis
again i'm aware that's what we're signed
up for
for what to make sure we do for for what
it's worth i think i think the video one
looks better i think that i do too yeah
that is the more recent one and those
changes we are planning to put to the
early
i'm just saying for goodness sake let's
get that consistency and get that review
done as i had asked last time please
i think you're going to end up having to
do that without me so please do it
a question from option can we control
the scroll value programmatically in
here the answer is yes right yes if in
this video what do i say here to control
the scope no no
no we cannot control the scroll value of
the gui programmatically
why not
the video stream setup functions allow
for that but not the video gui
sorry i didn't understand that if you
set if you evaluate this video
with some option
could you not set this to be that value
no
we don't have that
for example all the other controls like
manipulate you can do that
yeah i i see value in doing that
but i think carlo that goes back to our
discussion earlier that we need to store
the position in a video object
what the input form is of this gui that
you see
well that's a good question in its own
right isn't it yep and that's the reason
why we cannot we are not stirring the
position there
well what do you mean it's the reason
why you're not
i mean i don't understand that that this
is
why is it not stored there it could
perfectly well be stored there
what's the reason to not store it there
so the main reason is that we want
to be the video object to be the thing
that lives in kernel and then guise can
be different instantiations of the same
video object so you could see they could
have
independent positions but we want all of
those
instances to map to the same video
object in kernel oh no but that's not a
good explanation look you've got a sound
volume here are you telling me that that
the sound volumes of all things in a
grid are synchronized no they're not
you've got sound volume you can also
have video position
i tend to agree with you i
i would be hesitant adding it right away
in this release but apart from that i do
get
why this might be of interest
right i mean to me that would be exactly
what you might want to do you might want
to have something where you have a video
grid and every video is playing is
starting at a different place for
example
well and speaking of sound one might
want to programmatically control the
volume as well
which is which one can do right here
right no oh is it okay yeah yes i mean
presumably that's a sound volume option
for this yes carlo is that correct
correct
okay so i i just don't understand the
comment about kernels and anything else
i don't understand that comment this is
a video object if you
that that you will not like this
probably but if you change that sound
volume in degree i do not think that
changes the input form of the
kernel representation of that gui
same for appearance right
correct the appearance still looks as
automatic in the input form but why why
why i don't understand that's not how
the whole system works it could i
honestly don't see carla any problem
with that yeah
storing things explicitly
evidently was not done correctly
uh we will need to adapt some things
like how equality of videos for example
is computed
straightforward enough but
yeah one one related question minor is
that do we want equal and same q to
return true if these
gui related options are not the same
which i would say yes
no
no
same q and equal look at the whole thing
two videos
two videos set at different starting
points are different
for instance i think image
equal
is forgiving if the display size being
the image size option is different from
image one to image two
because all of the content is the same
if the metadata for the image is
different right correct
correct now i'm saying is this is this
considered to be display controls and we
should be forgiving if they are not the
same or are they considered to be actual
data or metadata
i think they're two different cases i
think there's a case
okay
i see so the issue is
right i mean so what does an animator do
what does animate do with respect to
that
john
uh with respect to what again
the stuff we were talking about storing
look oh um i don't
let's
don't remember off top of my head okay
so if i take this object here and i say
slash input form
yeah there we've got there it stored the
value
right
and has it stored the fact that it's not
playing
right now i'm not sure that it has
okay so guys you gotta look at this
together okay and see how each one of
these works
that make sense
yep
i also think the fact that we don't even
know for the animator means it's not
that important what this does initially
okay
ethan asks for video effect
um
video frame map can do anything of that
sort
more of these things should be coming
i i
it is it is very nice to see that people
expect us to do
uh ethan is asking stitching videos
together there's a stitching for
spherical images
and video
i don't think so
um
image registration and tracking is
showing its age
that's in the next next um
chunk of function updates in your
notebook and more is going to be coming
later yes it's aged
[Music]
okay
cells
ah various comments here
um
okay there are comments about fast
forward and fast backward in the video
player
you know the the
i don't know pretty standard controls
that go
faster slower etc etc etc speed it up
slow it down those kinds of things
we don't have anything yet again i think
those could be a part of a more advanced
gui
okay and they could also be accessed
through the dot dot button
sure that would be a kind of odd
place to put them yeah it would be
either there or in other settings well
yes but i mean
either that or we've got to have a yet
another icon that indicates go to the
more advanced uh
you know
controls
right
and in other players you can usually um
fast forward and fast backward from
sideways scrolling
what do you mean like this
um well
like when you hover over a video
and you use two
double clicks
no you know when you like sideways
scroll what do you horizontal scrolling
with
with fingers what do you call that like
on the magic magic mouse pad
slide left or right yeah when you slide
i don't know it scrubs through the video
it doesn't seem to work in youtube it
works on like it works on deal
real quick time and everybody else yep
yeah i don't know
just
mentioning but it doesn't yeah
okay
so okay so that's something for the
future
is worrying about
faster slower
speeds
ethan is suggesting adding larger public
domain movies into example data
we do have some of those well still not
big but i we are starting to put them in
put some of the famous scientific videos
that you know
there is more coming in resource data
and on the plan is web video search
if that's going to be good enough
um
yeah there's people commenting on the
cloud opening stuff
um
[Music]
sandra is commenting that scientific
videos
are often very big because they don't
have compression
that's a good point
because you don't want to miss something
i was also comment on that i think a lot
of the time scientific video tend to be
longer too
well like i guess yeah you'll find
longer ones in both scenarios
okay
sandra is commenting let's see
do what adobe illustrator and design and
so on
where assets are linked to the document
yes that's what we're planning
right yeah we're planning this kind of
asset bundle
asset linking type stuff
okay and sanders commenting that
relinking is commonly found in things
like the adobe products when assets
cannot be found
although there are definitely bad
patterns around here that we want to try
to avoid if we can i know i've seen some
horrible ones just completely crazy
loops you get into and things
um
the adobe stuff doesn't bundle but it
does collect so when you save you could
collect the associated files which might
be useful
different than kind of stored into some
zip or whatever
that's what i wanted us to do you know a
pass i mean it's too late for this
release but that's what i think is
useful let's say that you're going to
upload it you want it with all its
assets and properly re-linked
right that makes sense right
um
i don't think we can do that yeah um
ethan's talking about equalizer
what does an equal i don't know that
you mean for for sound levels
yes probably
i mean
this
equalizer has a very specific meaning in
audio it's probably not what he means
right
okay all right let's let's okay i think
this was our segment is there anything
more to say about the video player
oh we'll come back to it i'm sure
okay all right fine let's keep going
then on the other items
um here should
should we let go of john and christina
then i think so unless that is there
anything else for them here
um
well wait a minute fix recording
uh
jeremy should stay for video gradients
and things like this
um
[Music]
let's see uh
okay we had just started on these here
these video creation things right and
that definitely needs jeremy
um yes
okay fine
uh what was the thing with video
recording with multiple screens on what
is that what is video record
and now
no no video record i think it was a
video grid that we're talking about sort
of having i know but what does video
record what how can i record video from
my
is that
yeah that's the way to record from your
webcam or the screen
that's the programmatic way not the gui
based one and
that multiple screen on windows was an
issue we have in 12 3.
so if i say video record
it could be a string screen
which would start recording from your
screen
whatever the front end things are your
first screen what happens if i want to
record my webcam
uh you have to say dollar default
imaging device
or you can do dollar imaging devices and
pick the right one that you want to
record let's say i do this here
okay
so this is the handles to the recording
you can do video stop
and that should do okay
so now you construct a video from that
handle that you have in out 15 so you
just do video how do i just get a what's
the analog of audio capture
we don't have anything we based we
planned it for 13.1 yeah it's
tentatively planned okay so so how do i
get this video here you construct just
video of out 15.
okay
what
what
so that is some issue with recurring
that
probably comes out of prototype
okay but if i could do that
the video stream i could say video frame
list and i would be yeah yeah that would
be a normal video
so this is a pretty neanderthal video
recording setup so yeah yeah this is
like the programmatic way of doing it
yes very basic and
low level
also carlo that should also be an mp4 we
switch to mp4 for most other things
but let me comment on the programmatic
thing if you do this remotely on a
computer and it brings up that that uh
uh authentication dialogue what's going
to happen
i mean if i did this
i don't know maybe that's specific to
like the mac operating system or
something
i think it might be but yeah i i'm not
sure what so if i if i had a raspberry
pi was it with a with a camera on it
what would happen here
i i would assume you would have to give
permission to
vol from language to access the camera
in some way how would you not know if
the thing is just running
on linux for example i don't know
we'll have to find that out
okay
so for example here
if i say video grid
so let's say i take my
um
so let's say i've got a table a three by
three grid of those guys
why is this okay
fine and now i say video grid of this
is that right
yep yes
but it's got to know where
gosh
this is not a quick operation what is it
going to do is it going to
and how is it going to arrange that grid
what what kind of framing is it going to
put in there it is doing the same thing
in this case since you gave it an actual
matrix as
uh
image
assemble
yes
you gave it their structure the raw
images so it's going to be a lot of
these little critters yeah and this
slowness that you see is the encoding
and the coding is expensive yeah i'm not
surprised
so do you have an option in video grid
like in grid to put separators in
we do not have separators you could you
have spacing the spacings and control
the background
oh that's fine i mean but but
i there's a in grid there's a frame
arrow all and a frame you know those
things that's a really nice thing to
have here and there's a frame style
already available from grid yeah so we
followed more the
precedent of image compose and image
assemble rather than grid i know this is
called so you should do i i would i
would use flame and frame style as well
as well as spaces i think both are
useful
i think we're well beyond what christina
and i are needed for right
uh yes yes we are now okay great thank
you bye thanks thank you bye-bye
um okay
well we'll see what this does okay
video overlay
i see okay let's look at video overlay
where does it put it
by default we decided we put it at the
bottom left
or or
by them yeah i don't know i documented
one of the corners i don't think there
is an ideal location i would have
thought it was the top right corner
isn't that
my it might be uh
it'd be bottom right for me that's what
i expect
yeah bottom right bottom right okay what
fraction of the size jeremy
ooh uh
one-fourth maybe no it'd be yeah it'd be
smaller than that even
what we have implemented
where the size is of fixed size
as the size of the main video changes so
to speak
all right let us see the many many
critters here
oh wow
that's pretty cool
we haven't tested that much videos this
this big but it seems like it's doing
something sensible
what size of videos would you be testing
i mean this is a
did it down sample or did it i mean
this should be the full size of the data
so actually pretty big um let me i'll
get back to you
is it scaling to to get a time match or
does it require the exact number of
frames or time length
no it just puts frames it does scale if
the frame rates are different it
conforms that but apart from that it
puts things at the same time at the
next to each other
and then if one is sure there i i don't
know what we have decided to be the
default either we
stick empty
for the remaining ones or we end at the
shortest time
by the way this thing is slowing down
look at this i noticed that as well i
was gonna say for the video
gui we are still gonna have limitations
as i don't think it's a good something
is wrong
this you should debug this
especially as
yeah look at this this is really slow
too
so there was a memory leak
that hopefully has been fixed but i
don't know what the prototype status is
okay all right fine fine
turn on undocumented notebook frame rate
option
to see how slow it is okay
i don't know what that option is
it's undocumented and unknown to me okay
but video overlay
what was saying is the default
would be
placed
no that's crazy
crazy don't do that
putting an extra option to place
no no that isn't the main usage of place
we did we actually prefer for it not to
be there
yeah we marked that as future so that's
not
really it is not our ambition placed i
could have applied a function when i
placed things
you could have
if you click in that on that link you'll
see that those are the three usages that
i've documented
wowie i had no idea
okay that's useful to know no no we
asked brett before
using placed here
okay okay
all right so these pictures aren't quite
right because of the placement you're
saying
yep
okay correct and and jeremy you should
spec the size and i don't know what in
the aspect ratio
what's the aspect
well the aspect ratios are defined by
the videos yeah but
this thing here will have its placement
anchored but then it's got some aspect
ratio and it probably needs some if the
thing is a weird shape like for example
if it was a stripe at the bottom it
needs to handle its aspect ratio
correctly
you see what i'm saying
did you understand what i was saying if
you're trying to put a stripe at the
bottom of this video as the overlay
right don't make the mistake of saying
we're going to match heights and have
the stripe be a crazy size
did you understand
we we don't modify the maybe maybe i'm
missing something we don't modify the
size
we we just do place of
position bottom right or top right comma
top right which will
nicely align things but will not change
aspect ratios yeah the overlay is
overlaid at the original size if
somebody wants it at a different size
they have to resize yep
is there a video resize
there is gonna be image resize that's
another discussion on their video every
day
across frame how do you resize the whole
video for this purpose
well you could use you could reconstruct
a video using the rasters a different
raster size value
there's got to be an easier way to
decide how big the overlay is than
reconstructing a video with 17 different
options
right
i actually for video overlay i actually
agree i think it's going to be very
commonly wanted to specify the size
i think so too would style of
magnification work
i wouldn't do it that way i would just
say
on this thing
you know it's scaled blah blah blah
that's the size
will that work in any
point in place no right that there is no
space in place to have that
specification that's correct it's not
placed it will be instead saying
that um
instead what you will be doing
is more like you know scaled
you'd specify the rectangle basically
i mean in other words what i would do in
video overlay is just give the rectangle
yeah and
ethan is asking about multiple video
overlays
yeah you can have a list of those
okay so then
the question is
how would one give so those can have
place wrapped around them
correct
and they are independent replaced as
well they are independent
yeah i get that but the the issue is
what how to do the scaling for these
things
because placed is used to having
scaleless objects
well i mean obviously you could you
could have an arrow you know from the
overlay you could have overlay blah blah
blah or scaled arrow
and then that overlay
do you get what i'm saying
uh scroll down in the notebook another
thing that might be interesting is to
specify the time
at which the overlay is inserted so that
rule syntax
at least in that note i proposed as a
time goes forward right so basically
there's a space-time issue i mean yes in
principle one could have the overlay at
different times in different places on
the screen
correct
christina came back to ask a question if
you could go back to your notebook hold
on a second what what about this
position for the
oh i see that's the position christina
yes all you like to ask uh super quick i
noticed as i was leaving it looks like
there are two volume controls on the gui
is that what's happening those were
designed by billy as the volume control
and the device selection
device selection yes why is that oh it
looks
nice it's like that looks like a mute
button
that's both they're both volume
conventions aren't they yes yep
that's weird and here what's this one
oh no come on guys that's both no i know
we know stephen
well noticed
no no we know and i think uh we couldn't
manage to get the two combined in a nice
way
uh in a nicer way i agree if he can do
it in a combined way that's the more
correct way of doing that this is the
way right this this one here
has that exact thing
that's that has the combined volume
control so this
here on the other hand
for videos people usually have the mute
button right
yes
there's some work to do here why don't
you guys work with christina and others
and try and iterate this a bit let's not
get this wrong sure okay this looks i
mean these are rather straightforward
superficial things relative to all the
very complicated stuff that's already
been done let's not get this wrong
um
yeah i don't remember the details but i
think that's exactly what we aimed for
and
we couldn't get it straight carlo you
may remember
well no i mean this came
out of two issues uh the first one was
that
the wheel that double attached cell that
you see at the bottom
is
what prevents magnification from working
properly okay okay um guys there are a
bunch of technical issues we don't like
yes yeah why don't you go address them
and not end up with something where we
have inconsistent icons in two different
places meaning two different things
okay
and and if you need to come back for
this version and get some sort of hack
design invented then do that but why
don't we try and see what we think the
final design will be and then we'll hack
back if something is necessary for this
version
okay
okay meanwhile um
okay bye again okay thank you thanks
thanks
um
stacking gifts with transparency ethan
is asking about what happens if you want
a watermark on the video if you want an
overlaid watermark that's fine um
do not
oh sorry that was in one of the previous
iterations the the transparency got
dropped it is possible in the back end
but it is not exposed
okay but so there's some design issues
here because there's a bunch of features
here which i mean this video overlay
concept is a good concept but
okay so i'm assuming that in terms of
frame rates and so on you're just
dealing with that the frame rates
they will do something sensible
right
okay
um
what's this chroma keto background
subtracted video layers what's that
about it's a way to combine them
different ways to combine images okay
right okay all right fine but the things
we got to solve then is the space time
so one question is does the video
does the overlay video have the same
time base so to speak as the main video
or is it somehow offset like a sound
note
with this design they should cover
exactly the same there should be no
offset right because the video is not
necessarily right because i mean you
might want something
where there's an overlay that comes up
saying you
we're not solving this yet this this
still needs more
iteration um
okay we've still got quite a bit to do
here i just want to look with jeremy
just for a minute
at what have we come up with here we
this was not the name we ended up by
as a procedural thing when we come back
and do a replay of one of these design
reviews please can you edit the
the notebook to reflect what we've
already figured out
like check marks or something
no i mean
not that but i mean things we've changed
in the design
right roger
okay what did we change this to last
time snippets video
okay
okay so now graphics to a video is a
very interesting concept
summary video as well we discussed some
things that you might want to look at
the ref page for it based on what we
discussed last time
which is now called snippets video
snippets video no it's still called
summary video in cvs
so see that second argument spec and all
the string
uniform random scene change
as a way of specifying where to pick
from
by the way it's either seen changes or
scene change yes that's the changes
plural
sounds good
for scenes in the metadata of the video
sometimes
where do you get that information from
this is something that's discovered by
analyzing the video we don't ah nice
okay okay so i think that it needs a
little bit of testing before we are sort
of confident in it and stuff do you
really want to call it scene changes
because it might be some other dramatic
you know an explosion happens is that a
scene change and you know the whole
screen turns orange or something
that you would pick that up with the
machine learning stuff but it isn't a
quote scene change
does that make sense you understand what
i'm saying
yeah i do understand what you say
okay
what we are planning to implement here
is as you guessed uh a dramatic change
in scene
necessarily
a scene question is that adequately
called a scene change even when it might
not be
stage direction you know now showing the
person in the getaway car or something
you know you know what i'm saying yep
it's not necessarily a scene change in
that sense unless in that business
come to mean
dramatic change of video
do you understand the point yeah salient
moments even though that might be over
promising a bit no that that might be a
different thing
but i also think that the people that
understand salient yeah hopeless
hopeless how about just change or
changes
yeah yep
and also an additional argument that can
take is a scale parameter that says how
much change is assumed to be a change
i think we really need to test this
before i kind of trust this i just but
also this part is a realistic uniform
random
i see it's really at changes
uniform at random at changes
wait a minute changes
i see this is where the timestamps are
which is what you should say because
every one of these says timestamps right
so this is really what this should say
instead of spec is basically
timestamps or something
times
right
yeah probably should even if there are
many ways of doing it indirectly
right
but so
this is times
and this is saying
yeah that's fine so it's changes
um
right
okay
yeah ethan is commenting
basically saying we should be able to
get a timeline plot out of a video if we
can do the changes thing we should be
able to do a timeline part of the video
which is true we should be able to get
video frameless
in addition to summary video
video frame lists should be able to take
changes
bring up that
page updated
okay what is a keyframe
as opposed to a scene change
keyframes uh it seems to be stuff that
people when or when they're compositing
videos they just uh mark some some
frames as keyframes it
how you recognize it coming out
uh there is a flag at every frame that
we can read i see so i think that the
science on the compression is used it's
like in in the keyframes full image
disturb and then just for the next and
images only the changes are stirred
okay so that's purely a compression
thing that doesn't seem super
super useful
no i i think it really depends on the
video but in general yeah i would not
expect i think let's change the
languages guys this makes sense for
video frame list at changes so to speak
okay very quickly just for a minute here
because this is going to require a
separate discussion
video tour
unfortunately the output is completely
un intuitive what's going on
uh i'm sorry so
we were discussing just earlier with
charlie how to make these examples so
you could understand what is actually in
the video rather than displaying three
frames that are completely static
unrelated to the function sorry
okay
all right
but so okay so oh that's a dead animal
yeah that's that's what it has to be
because of this
asset problem but that the discussion
carlo and i had which he mentioned is to
have animated image
applied to all of these videos and then
basically a mini version of that video
is going to be stored in the notebooks
yeah it looks like the prototype has
some issues with our backend
sorry
bob is commenting that keyframes can be
decoded without looking at surrounding
frames which is useful
just from that so this is dead is that
what you're telling me this i think all
video functionality might be dead
because of back-end upgrades
in profit i'm sorry what
abort this as soon as it's not killing
your mathematical if you can
might already be late we were doing
other videos but you're saying graphics
to a video is not functioning this one
yeah this one made my hang as well
okay
but
but jeremy
what this is have you seen this before i
haven't no i can kind of guess what it
is
right
is it following a path is it following
these points do you want to let carlo
demo that is it linear
yeah it is linear
you could uh change hello do you want a
demo
yeah
really out of time here so
go ahead okay
go for it